[Music]
okay has anybody here been cheated on
before
and how did you find out oh yes i have
have you yeah
it's weird you know what the last the
last woman that was in a serious
relationship uh
cheated on me and she she cheated on me
with a [ __ ] oh
and she was like how did you cheat at
church well the [ __ ]
you know what i take uh a little bit of
responsibility yes right
it's never your fault if someone cheats
on i'll tell you this though he's like
but i cheated on her first
let me tell you something i hooked her
up i thought i was watching
but it what happened was like i'm so
at this point i was so just into
whatever or what i was doing right and
she had a certain perception of what a
boyfriend is
like they always check in on you they
see what's up i didn't know that
so [ __ ] so i i just like for example
it's good that's secure well this is the
last draw was she went to vegas right
and then all i said was hey have a good
time and let me know when you're back
and then you're safe that's all i did
but i didn't call to see if she was okay
there i didn't call her on her right
back
and she felt very what are you a [ __ ]
worried mother that's
the [ __ ] made [ __ ] is she korean sounds
like this yeah she's korean
and so what are you doing
so check this [ __ ] out right so
julie's on you guys all know oh yeah
yeah so julie's on and i have been
friends for a very long time yeah
all right so uh she nice name drop she
didn't she didn't like
the way that my friendship was with with
julie
right too close she felt like it was
intimate she was too hot
no not getting jelly you're amazing
no but she's just fun it's like you get
really comfortable real quick
yeah and i've known julie for [ __ ]
years right we've been friends for a
very long time
so before we actually got to uh got
together
i asked her i was like do my female
relationships make you feel
uncomfortable
and if it does because she's actually
was friends with julie before
i was like if you don't like the way
that we interact i'll i'll have a
conversation with her easy she goes no i
love
julie she's great that's fine lo and
behold she was [ __ ] lying to my face
so well that's not fair in a
relationship exactly and by the way
her [ __ ] that [ __ ] sent her to the
[ __ ] moon was
me my brother julie and her went to have
dinner together
this is four people this is not me and
julie alone and i hadn't seen julie at
that point for like seven or eight
months
and so she felt a certain way because we
were joking around but she has to
know i've known her four or five years
before i met you so this is
it doesn't [ __ ] matter so that night
she decides to leave early she goes yeah
after dinner she just left
well she left that night to go meet up
some other dude out of anger
out of spite so it's out of jealousy you
know
she's also in everyone's mac book look
at how pretty julie is right because
she is the asian girl on the photo booth
yes the [ __ ] icon that's her
oh [ __ ] that's why she looks so familiar
and behold she whatever [ __ ] does her
[ __ ] nice name drop
you know i'm i'm such a i'm such a nice
guy or whatever what and i'm fantastic
by the way you're the best she started
feeling guilt
and then she just said like i cheated on
you i wanted this man the way she sucked
this dick
dude you said there was so much rage i
was mad for you man nobody
she's like oops it's like his dick no
julie's
she's not the one that she didn't no she
didn't cheat she's the she's the sister
no she's a friend i'll google district
what's her name
you almost did it guys type in grace
park hey it's on patreon your friend
great spa type and grace
sarah what the [ __ ] name is you yeah
esther parker's name
uh helen uh
i know one of us got something right so
here's the funniest [ __ ] right
yeah so joseph vincent and uh jason chen
were at my house when i found this out
so i was on the phone with her and she
started telling me the [ __ ] and i got
the phone on the phone because she
actually she was she was in pharmacy
school at the time
so she was in school and i'm hearing
this [ __ ] and i'm so like
what's the word so stereotypical oh i'm
sorry that one yeah
frustrated i was like i got so
[ __ ] angry i stopped i punched a
[ __ ] hole through my door
at this apartment i was smashing myself
that's david's signature move yeah i was
so [ __ ] mad
and then you hear you just hear jason
chet adjusted joseph vincent
trying to do a music video on my
apartment
he's in the back turn the lipstick to
their song while i'm like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
bow bow bow and then you should just
[ __ ] jason chen lip sync you in the
background
yeah but yeah i got i got cheated on but
then after that we
we broke up and then i i started yeah i
got over my anger really fast though
because i was like
why am i angry like just walk it's
really about deep down yeah dude just
break up and move on yeah
and then we broke up and we and i moved
on and that was it happily ever after
all yeah
well a woman found out that her
boyfriend was cheating on her after she
checked her blocked list on instagram so
her her boyfriend took her phone
blocked the chick that he's cheating on
her with
on her instagram account damn that's
next left i thought he was smart huh he
was like yo
i'm kind of a [ __ ] cat burglar
dancing's next
she was only blocking one woman she's
like i'm going through my block list and
i was like wait a minute who's this girl
so she moved from england to the us to
be with her boyfriend and then
she had a weird feeling about him and
she
checked her blocked list and found the
chick that he was cheating on her with
wow number one i don't know how many
people check their block list so that's
interesting to me yeah
so we're gonna have a block list i don't
i don't even know my blog
if you if you give a check a reason
she'll grow a [ __ ] pumpkin in her
head
is that a figure of speech no it's a
real deal a girl
i always said that if a girl has a
suspicion of something
she's a better detective than a [ __ ]
30-year vet detective
in the police for real if you fired all
of the fbi and just put jealous ass
[ __ ] instead
god oh my god bro there's no crime in
all the crimes
over it's over and reduced the
government budget
yeah for you only need 30 jealous
shooters
because they're gonna waste money well
you don't have to pay women as much so
that's
great yeah the whole pay gap thing right
hey
thank god for the pay cap pay gap is
like a swish
right we would pay way less taxes oh
no never trust you about anything oh
every time
it's like did you do the laundry of
course i did she goes really and then
she just swipes the dust she goes
[Laughter]
clearly you have it done at 4 pm yeah
and you see little texts on the side
yeah
she finds red underwear that aren't hers
and i'm like hey the pay gap
isn't that [ __ ] isn't that [ __ ]
we got to fix that
i'm so glad you brought that up steve
oh dude i don't even know it
uh yeah so she's like hey i checked this
[ __ ] out i've never
seen this girl before why would i block
this girl that's the
girl that's blocked or she's already
cheated on chick oh
and so she's like i don't know what's
going on this is pretty sad yeah she
moved from
uk to be with them dude that sucks
and then um yeah she finds out her
boyfriend did it
and that's a huge commitment to be
uncommitted
you know what i mean i i know exactly i
mean so sad
uh so took a big she took a big gamble
and lost he pro if he probably didn't
even block her
he probably would have got caught i
don't know he seems like a dumbass
though
yeah but he thought he was thinking 10
steps ahead but he put himself in the
rocker uh her ig maybe he wants to leave
stupid comments as she like
versus like what does that mean they
were all mutual friends with this other
girl
like that that the girlfriend was
already following this other girl
she could leave comments and she won't
see it but dude this chick is next level
right
so she finds out that her boyfriend
cheated and she sent him a necklace
with all the girls names on them i'll
see you also it's multiple women
what she commissioned the necklace yo
necklace bro dude
that's like petty ass [ __ ] i love this
chick i was married
to all the girls too was that did she
hit up all the girls too yeah
[ __ ] yeah cheating is a lot of work and
i have way too much anxiety to cheat
i i want to see like her hit up all the
girls and then
they all meet up together and beat this
dude up
but my porno mind comes up and i'm
thinking
they're going to forgive him and they're
going to have a huge orgy
wait what all the girls have dicks what
the [ __ ] is that
really what what is that what is that oh
this is the necklace and she put all the
names of the chicks that he
cheated on her with on the necklace and
three girls plus
yep dude she made a [ __ ] jewelry
piece that had their names on it she's
very normal but
this is normal [ __ ] just away wait 14
[ __ ] business days for it to come in
and [ __ ] yeah
like if that happened to me i would look
at it i was like how much did that cost
like fourteen hundred dollars you could
have just told me
you wasted 1400 bucks now i'm going to
melt this and why do you hate me more
than 1400
that's why the budget would go to waste
that's why we didn't work
he's just like oh [ __ ]
i was like yeah bro this is my [ __ ]
list
bro sometimes guys are so dumb the girls
plan do backfire
yeah that's what i'm saying dude yeah
that's point six etherium is stupid
[ __ ] you could have hurt me by just
sending it to a burn address you know
i always wonder for you because you've
been with tiff for so long would you
know how to talk to women now how long
how long
i've been waiting for high school
sweethearts huh yeah eleven years
[ __ ] do you even know how to flirt can i
okay can i ask you i'm asexual just get
one question we'll cut it if you don't
like it
so when it's time when you want to [ __ ]
yeah
how do you approach your wife now you've
been with her for this long yeah do it
on me
you know what do you want somebody it's
the whole process
why do you look like a [ __ ] sex slave
dude
you look like a brick
he literally looked at you like he was
waiting for a gunshot on the face
he didn't see anything so i thought
i didn't see him more in geology he's
not getting out of here but bro
i'm taking you home you want me to do my
[ __ ] spreading push-ups dude yeah dude
i don't need you too
by the way i don't need you to dude uh
yeah
i don't know can you just talk is there
a seduction or you just talk
it's just it's just when it happens it
happens kind of
like i don't even have a game of my own
wife bro
that's what i was definitely suspecting
low-key just kind of happened
like you just in bed and you touching
and [ __ ] touching we just start kissing
and [ __ ] so it's not verbal
she started playing with my [ __ ] you
know what i mean
i love my [ __ ] getting played you guys
talk [ __ ] yeah what's up hey
you guys don't be like all right this
one's gonna go down game plan to be 100
honest with you so
i got to see a scenario you are now tiff
you are
you're [ __ ] sorry ass nick and i want
you can't be
yeah so nick uh you want to have sex
yeah and that is and guys this isn't
full body contact thank you
so we're usually cuddling bro and
where's your [ __ ] logo no no my [ __ ]
my back [ __ ] bro my back we're like
cuddling [ __ ] and then we're like
watching tv and i started looking look
first move yeah
start grabbing titty bro oh
you have to play like you don't want it
yeah bart come on you got to start
turning away
you're tired bar you have a headache
it's so clear that you want it right now
so if you could just change up
parts a little bit bart you're watching
ufc you're like i'm already watching
your stupid show i've been doing social
work all day
i've been doing social media that's how
she talks bro and i started you stole
from target
yeah and then and then look like i start
sticking my hooks in
oh and i start choking my seatbelt seat
belt seat belt seat belt
and i screw it in here and then she goes
out and then she wakes up
forgets about everything and i'm like yo
what's up baby start kissing oh
and then you get that and then i start
grabbing the meow bro that's what it is
it's the ass tree straight up i'm
[ __ ] gay guys
hey bro this is how it goes my hands on
his head he's like uh-huh
uh-huh i'm a proud gay man you just got
molested by me dude
that's what kevin spacey said when he
[ __ ] up
so i'm going with that i just [ __ ] up
with my own head in my pants